[Music]
foreign
I'm freaking out here okay there's a guy
that called and said that there's a bomb
underneath the car and if we get out
it'll blow up
stop just stop doing that no I don't
understand Matt he said we're gonna die
because of you okay stop stop but what
else did he say wait you know him
stop would you stop doing that please
please
what else did he say I don't know I
don't know stop he said to wait for you
until you arrive that's it so there you
are
not just stop it for one second I don't
know what you're saying could you please
be quiet for one second please
I'm freaking out here man I know you are
me too but it's important that you stay
calm for you to stay safe come there's a
bomb underneath the car
listen to me okay listen to me listen to
me I called me too
together we're in what together
okay well what did you do to him I
didn't do anything I need you to focus
did he say anything else no no no I
don't want to die Matt I have a family
no what are you doing he said give me
the [__] dude
you're not going to die you just need to
stay calm and think I am going to die if
you don't
just be quiet
[Music]
foreign
are you gonna answer that
it's not mine
[Music]
sorry who is this
do I have your attention
that I do something to you you sound so
guilty what do you want drive to this
location
honey Something's Happened there's a man
who's put a bomb in the car under our
seats there are pressure triggers
we can't get up the car will explode
we're here listen very careful or I kill
you open the glove box
why are you doing this what have I ever
done to you this life or yours Matt I'm
your best friend
foreign
I guess you've had a tough day
I know that you've lost a lot of money
for your clients who invested in your
fund
a lot of people are worried about you
you've got everybody's attention Matt
oh
it's all out there
if I will
son of a [__] I will kill you
What's it gonna be
Drive
[Music]